one evening Gregor found his little
brother playing with a toy by the fire
Gregor's toy a wooden Knight Gregor
never said a word he just grabbed his
brother by the scruff of his neck and
shoved his face into the burning coals
held him there while the boy screamed
Wireless face melted
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
a prediction video in today's video I
want to talk about that great scene we
got between the Hound and its brother
the mountain during the meeting at the
dragon pit in this season 7 finale this
was one of the most anticipated moments
in the last few seasons and although we
didn't all get cleganebowl I still think
this scene was satisfying in another way
I know I can't speak for everyone but
personally I've been waiting for this
day to come for quite some time pretty
much since the first season at least
that was when we got our first taste of
how good the Coe game Bowl could be when
you learn what the mountain did to his
brother you can't help but hope the
Hound gets some form of payback
eventually it's bad enough that the
mountain stuck his face into a fire when
he was a little boy but that isn't all
the mountain has done the hounds hatred
for his brother runs so much deeper than
only that there are some things you can
learn about the mountain in the books
that just go to show you how violent
this man actually is everyone should
already know what he did to Elia Martell
and her children which is why Oberyn
Martel was so angry with him but let me
read to you this one chapter from the
books I think you will find this just as
interesting as I did it's pretty damn
creepy and it further shows what the
Hound had to deal with when growing up
with him as a brother
this was actually in one of ned stark's
chapters in the first book and at the
time he is thinking about the mountain
and some of the stories he has heard
about him Ned seldom put much stock into
gossip but the things said of Sir Gregor
were more than ominous the mountain was
soon to be married for the third time in
one her dark whisperings about the
deaths of his first two wives it was
said that his keep was a grim place
where servants disappeared unaccountably
and even the dogs were afraid to enter
the hall and there had been a sister who
died young under queer circumstances in
the fire that had disfigured his brother
the Hound in the hunting accident that
had killed their father Gregor Clegane
had inherited to keep the gold in the
family estates his younger brother
Sandor had left the same day to take
service with the Lannisters as a sworn
sword and it was said that he had never
returned not even to visit I remember
when I first read that chapter I was
like holy [ __ ] I knew the mountain was
crazy when he stuck his brother's face
into the fire but he is a complete
Psychopaths it basically implies that
the mountain murdered his first two
wives then he murdered their younger
sister and their father during a hunting
trip and the damn servants at their
keeper constantly going missing he
pretty much murders everyone he comes
into contact with including all of his
family members and wives even the damn
dogs are afraid of the mountain and the
dogs are actually the sigil of his house
that's how crazy the mountain is and
this just goes to show you why the hound
has so much hatred for his brother so
when the hound confronted his brother at
the dragon pit I was very excited but I
was also intrigued because the hound
said something very interesting to his
brother something I have been trying to
decipher but I'm not sure if I'm any
closer to solving this than when I first
heard it but let's take a look at the
scene then try to take a guess at what
he actually meant
remember me yeah you do
you're even [ __ ] uglier than I am now
what do they do to you
doesn't matter it's not how it ends for
you brother you know is coming for you
you've always known all right now let's
take a closer look at this the hound
asks his brother what did they do to you
then he says it doesn't matter it's not
how it ends for you brother you know
who's coming for you
you've always known clearly the hound
knows something that we don't but the
question is what does he know and who is
he referring to when he says you know
who's coming for you
I think the most obvious answer is the
hound was referring to himself the hound
has more than enough reasons to kill the
mountain himself and if I had to pick
anyone to do the job I would pick the
hound because that would be the most
satisfying what Gregor did to the hound
has traumatized him his entire life and
it has had such a long-lasting effect on
him it has even caused other people to
be hurt and even killed the best example
of this was when the Hound went beyond
the wall with joining company when they
were attacked by the white polar bear
the Hound completely froze up when the
bear was on fire and this was when
Thoris stepped in to protect the Hound
which ultimately led to Thoreau's dying
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the hound may never totally get over his
fear of fire but if he were to kill his
brother I think it would certainly help
heal some of those wounds I would like
to think the hound has threatened to
kill him at some point after he was
burned after the mountain put his face
in the fire the hound may have told him
that one day he would kill him for that
which would explain why the hound told
him he has always known who would come
for him and kill him one day that makes
the most sense to me but the way the
hound said that during this scene it
almost seemed like the Hound was
referring to something else or someone
else but then you have to ask yourself
who else could the Hound mean how would
he know for a fact that someone else
will kill the mountain and how would the
Hound know that his brother knew this
day would come - is it possible that the
Hound may have seen or heard something
else in the flames there are at least
two different times the Hound could have
possibly seen or heard something in the
flames that we know of
it could be similar to how Varys heard
something into flames when Varys was
just a boy he had something very
traumatic happened to him - and that was
of course when the sorcerer cut off
varus's genitals and threw them in the
fire when this happened Varys had
something in the flames something that
has haunted him his entire life
maybe something similar happened to the
Hound when his brother put his face into
the fire the Hound was also a young boy
when this happened and it was also very
traumatic for him just like it was for
Varys with that in mind do you think the
Hound could have heard something in the
flame something referring to his brother
being killed we know for a fact that the
Hound saw something in the flames when
he was with thoris of mirror and beric
Dondarrion during that scene the Hound
only mentioned seeing the army of the
Dead moving to eastwatch-by-the-sea but
there is a chance he saw more than that
and it could have something to do with
his brother this is probably a stretch
though I don't really see how the
mountain would know the night King was
coming for him - the Hound did tell his
brother he knew who was coming for him
so I don't know how the mountain would
know the night king or the army of the
Dead would be coming for him unless it
had something to do with the mountain
being undead the mountain is technically
a white just a different kind of white
but I do wonder if the night Keane could
take control of the mountain if he tried
the mountain doesn't seem to have the
same kind of free well that Jon Snow and
beric Dondarrion have all three of them
have been brought back from the dead but
the mountain is the only one who acts
like a zombie s quite as far as we know
the mountain doesn't even speak anymore
which makes him more of a white than
anyone else who has been living south of
the wall there is another person to
hound could have been referring to when
he confronted his brother he could have
been talking about Arya Stark
everyone knows Arya Stark has wanted the
mountain dead for a very long time Arya
has been scratching names off for her
hit list and the mountain was still one
there the last time she recited those
names when Arya was at the house of
black and white in season six she said
the names on her list and she only named
three people who else was Anaya stalks
funny LITTLEST sassy Lannister
Grego go gain
will defray Aria already removed Walder
Frey from the game but she could take
Cersei in the mountain out at almost the
same time if given the right opportunity
the Hound is also well aware of aurea's
list when the Hound an Oreo were
traveling together he heard Oreo recite
all of the names on her list so he knows
hooria wants to kill the mountain woman
beric Dondarrion
the rest of mare in pain the mountain
would you shut up I can't sleep until I
say the names the names of every [ __ ]
person in Westeros only the ones I'm
going to kill huh
hates that's good the thing is Annie to
keep a person doing better than most we
come across my brother maybe we can both
cross a name off a list Arya has always
been a top candidate to kill the
mountain but the only problem I have
with this is the mountain does not know
Arya wants to kill him The Hound told
his brother he knew who was coming for
him so I'm not really sure how the
mountain would know Arya is coming
unless someone told him but I don't
remember ever seeing that scene I think
there is a slight chance the Hound may
have been talking about Arya and there
might be a slight chance the Hound saw
or heard something in the flames but I
think the safest bet is the helm being
the one to actually kill his brother
himself I know some people were tired of
hearing about cleganebowl because it's
been hyped up for so many seasons now
but I do think the helm was referring to
himself when he told his brother he knew
who was coming don't get me wrong though
it would be very interesting if he meant
Arya or the night King I just don't know
how the mountain would know this but if
you have a different theory please put
it down below because I would love to
hear it I know some people have been
thinking the Helmand Arya Stark or the
night King so I figured I would address
this a little bit in the video but
personally I am still one board the hype
train for a Clegane Bowl so let me know
if you are too
lately
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
either way I want to thank all of you
for watching the video I appreciate that
as always I also want to thank all of
you who continue to support the channel
on patreon it does mean a lot to me I
hope you all have a great day I will see
you in the next one bye
[Music]
you